okay to people joining this live stream
this is a wolfram language design review
language completeness and consistency
review
where we have a variety of topics to
discuss
okay graph vertex names that are lists
um charles is presumably here right
um yes i'm here okay so can you tell us
what the problem is
well oh
well you sent an e you steven sent an
email
to t uh lcc
with uh you know that first bullet point
is the entire content of the email okay
charles knows what the issue is right
charles yes i
know what else issues um so essentially
the you know the use of you know list
in half have several issues right
in most of the cases like that that
should that should work
fine but sometimes used as
a you know second argument and such
right yeah next argument of what oh
so when you have a function like um
let's see
a function which need to take a vertex
for example
let's see you know this component out
component
i see so i'm going to take this graph
here
and we say um
vertex out component of percent 22
and now we say list a b
did that work or not um
yeah in this case that's work i mean so
that's why it's more i
classified this as more a bug a general
issue we just need to go through graph
and fix that
um essentially you know we want both to
be able to support you know vertices and
lists also you know
kind of feel stability for but if i were
to say
graph a goes to c
c goes to a you know a goes to c
or something like this and now i were to
say vertex out component
of that comma list ac
i can't even tell whether that's right
or wrong in this case right so i'd say
a goes to d for example um
is this right or wrong um
okay but so so what is the um
um
what's what's a failing case uh okay
charles is this just a bug
yes it's just a bug like the case of
nested craft is just a bug
so so which is the actual bug or
there's uh there's a i found the bug
about nested graph 405251
let me see if i can get an example from
there
there is next graph where it's obvious
and there is also some function where
there are corner cases
right where we essentially if you give
us a list we need to check
if it's you know the list that list is
first a vertex or is it
a list of vertex so some of the
implementation for some function we
don't do that correctly i see i see so
so you're prepared to go and do
a content dependent test yes
i mean you could have a weird thing
where there's both the vertex that is a
list and isn't a list what do you do in
that case
um so in that case we give the
precedence to the vertex so
if you okay and you're going to document
that
yes but now what if
i mean to me it seems like if you really
want the list
maybe you should be able to say verbatim
of the list
um yeah we can actually also support
that
fine
um the baiting is not a hold-all thing
is it
no uh verbatim is not about you hold
pattern is obviously hold all verbatim
is not
and and right that that's why literal
the old literal was split into hold all
on verbatim precisely to
to you know clarify those two
different things so verbatim does not
hold anything okay fine
okay so it sounds like it's just a bug
and we might have this verbatim extra
functionality but then we're done on
this issue
yes okay good stuff
it'll be nice because nest golf is a
mess right now
so so charles with authentics extend to
[Music]
like the vertex replace case that i was
discussing with you earlier this year
um i'm not sure i don't recall exactly
right so where i was trying to do i
wanted to do vertex replace of graph
list of vertices goes to list of
coordinates oh
why do right you wanted to have the
you know left you know the left hand
side just one hole with you know
at least on the left hand side down the
list on the right hand side
correct what um
no unless we you know we decided here
for me
vertex replace was more behaving like um
replace
so you have to match you know the left
to the right without doing a trading
it doesn't trade
right but part of the reason at the time
that it couldn't thread was because
you know the list on the left hand side
could be a vertex itself
right that's also one point yep so okay
um while we're at it i i don't want to
hijack this conversation but
but um there were two other graph
related things that i wanted to raise
one is at what point do we get to do
um graph rewrites because we we now have
tons of code from the physics project
for doing graph rewriting
and it seems like we should figure out a
design bridge so that we can actually do
graph rewriting directly here
um i know whether you've looked at that
at all charles
um yes i did look a little bit a while
back actually
when we got some of the code i think we
should probably just
put that in the list of a project right
well we probably should just
do a design meeting where we try and go
through i mean i think that there's a
whole theory
of of you know what's called double push
out rewriting
um that it all has to do with where the
hairs of the
rewritten you know the the pattern graph
how do its
hairs its tentacles it's um i forget
they have a more technical name for it
now i used to call them hairs
the things that stick out that are kind
of half edges if you understand what i'm
saying
yes how do those connect in okay we
should look at that okay
first point second point graphs with
ports we're going to need graphs with
ports
that is you know what i mean by that yes
and why is it
that syntactically we can't be using
an association type syntax
for or am i crazy here for the
i mean basically what we have to do is
label from a given node i mean like like
in our trees
technology we are we essentially have
ports by virtue of the ordering of the
edges coming out of a tree uh
you know of a tree node but we don't
have that for graphs because it doesn't
matter
this thing here doesn't care what order
it's in right
right
do you have a a a um a suggestion for
how to represent
graphs with ports um yes actually we
you know we actually i think i actually
had a
proposal a while ago i will chase that
down and probably have a meeting for the
design
if i remember correctly it was just a
actually more
happen where we can just specify the
different type of part and associate it
to do all right so so maybe we can get
um who's who's pm'ing here i'm forgotten
again
uh it's seven yes
okay that's taken over okay great um
okay so uh you know
we should have a a custom design meeting
about ports in
graphs um
neural nets tensors
because i claim they're all the same
thing
and i claim and this is a something for
jose
i claim that the string diagram
methodology
aka tensor networks is is all a story of
graphs with ports
and maybe jose can comment i mean you
know when you have a tensor
and you're sort of threading through
different tensor indices to represent
contractions and so on
that is effectively a graph but it's a
graph with ports
because it can be the the the nth index
of a given
tensor is the one that threads to
something else
does that make any sense so so can
somebody define ports for me because
okay so here's what i mean
so we've got a graph and like like let's
take let's take a trivial graph
okay let's take the graph one goes to
two one goes to three
one goes to four okay there it is
okay right now
this edge there's
you you can say this is port number one
this is port number two this is port
number three
of that vertex okay
okay but but it isn't a label of the
edge
it's a label you can think of this
as this vertex so so in neural nets
the way this works we have this notion i
don't even know how
let's see if i say um net graph here
okay when i when i look at um why is it
this thing this raft has a habit of
running away
which i think has gotten why is that
spinning why did that take
any time to start up or whatever okay
all right so here
let's see where is it showing this
anybody know how this works here
what this is basically the point is go
ahead yeah yeah right so uh
are are we thinking of this as sort of
like slots in the tensor so
riemann has the first one is an up slot
and then
three down slots and then you get
richie by you know contracting the first
and third leaving
two down slots right but you can think
of that as the tensor having ports
right okay so
um yeah oh jonathan is here why is
jonathan here well
i'm happy that jonathan is here he's
commenting that dummy indices the
standard terminology and string well
that's determined dummy dummy indus
dummy oh dummy vertices
as opposed to dummy indices um
can you try what i put in chat stephen
yes yes
um
what on earth is this
oh what is that where did that come from
it's one of the things that we were
working on when we were developing
symbolic tensors where are we
the one of the are the riemanns
and the and the red parts are the
constructions
okay now jonathan who's revealed his
presence um
can you comment on how this relates to
string diagrams or
well okay jose and or jonathan penrose
notation string diagrams whatever how do
they relate to this
i think this was i mean this is the idea
of birth tracks that we have discussed
sometimes
okay so let me understand so these black
things are riemanns
is that right yes and these these red
things
are but i don't understand why the
riemanns are connected
so each node here represents
an index of the rune is that right yes
and then this is saying but but what
we're not getting here is the naming
of the ports of the riemann right
internally they are numbered so one of
these nodes is a one another two and
then
tensor contract is it is naming the the
ones that are contracted
right
okay i understand that but so so this
will be a case
where
i mean what i'm trying to understand is
when you have neural nets for example
and or you know you're connecting
you know in a net graph you are
connecting these networks these networks
are tensors
and you're connecting certain legs of
one tensor to legs of another tensor
and that's being done with ports here
this this is the
for net with multiple input ports port
arrow data
that by the way somebody should note
addison that that's for you perhaps
is a uh there's a font incorrect there
got it uh um in fact multiple of these
are incorrect
somebody goofed up here oh sigh
okay um
i had never seen this before when was
this put in like a decade ago or
something
yep
uh okay i mean i don't remember
could we just think it's not useful
enough or why did we decide not to
actually expose this because you see
it's in the
symbolic tensors context well we could
certainly put it as a function
repository item these days
we were exploring ways of expressing the
contractions
but i mean i think it was never clear
whether it was this was the right thing
because as the stephen was saying
it's not clear whether attention should
be a single node
or a bunch of nodes as here what are
they in
in the you know bird tracky type
world the standard thing is to have each
tensor
having a shape for example riemanns are
typically
squares but other tensors have
shapes that encode their symmetries
and so but the symmetry of the riemann
tensor is pretty complicated
yes but i mean here i'm in in the
assumptions line i'm not
representing the symmetry but we could
there is there is internally a symbolic
tensor's riemann symmetry
object and then for example potential
reduce could
realize whether this is zero or not via
the contractions
i think so sorry i i got i got
distracted by something could you could
you say that again
yeah so that the the third argument of
arrays
can represent symmetries and internally
we have ways of of expressing the
riemann
symmetry which is some permutation
some collection of permutations some
yeah
okay some of which have minus signs and
others of which do not okay um right but
he
right he didn't declare the symmetry
just declared it a rank for
tensor right so what i was saying is
that the standard thing is to have
the same tensor with the same shape so
here we see the
this similarly looking black tensors but
they have different shapes
yeah yeah well fine but i mean
that we could as well in the charles ian
world
have something where it's a ported
vertex
which could also be a shaped vertex i
mean we have not
pulled out the concept of a you know
there's no
high-level description language for
shaped vertices is that true charles
um yes but we could have that
yes
especially that's when you start to do
drawing and grammatical language
and you actually
need that um
okay jonathan who seems to be audio
challenged
is um uh sending through some
what the heck is this i i
all right what is this this is going to
be a zx
oh well it's a 4x4 matrix
represented in zx calculus
right so this is a this is a sensor
network or if you like a string diagram
where each of these represents
so each of the vertices is a two by two
matrix
so the the the green vertices being um
z rotate uh z rotations about the blocks
for the red vertices being
x rotations about the block sphere and
then as in any string diagram
it's when they're stacked in parallel
that's a tensor product when they're
stacked in series that's a an ordinary
composition okay so to be specific here
this we we have don't we we have a poly
matrix
so this is the x poly matrix
is that and the z power matrix
is this right yep so they would be poly
matrices for the in the case where the
phases are pi
so like the the the green thing that
with label pie
is a is a z-pali matrix
okay but in general more generally that
they can have arbitrary phases but
i don't know whether we should give
pauli matrix a second argument
is there any reason no i mean these
aren't poundly matrices right they they
are just z and x rotation matrices
um but in what sense
yeah oh i see i the matrix x are they
just the matrix exponent
are they true rotation matrices so
they're the exponential of the
poly matrices no they're not they're no
they're not okay
okay so but they're ordinary rotations
so they're not part of the spinner
representation
no okay um but anyway the the the point
i was trying to make was a purely
structural one which is just that so
you can see this this has two input
ports two output ports which corresponds
to the fact that there are two
it has effectively it takes an input
that is a tensor
product of two qubits and gives an
output that's a tensor product of two
qubits
and so we rep in this particular way of
representing it we just show those
essentially as vertices that are
invisible
uh and where the ports are labeled so
here you can see the input ports are
called i1 and i2
and the output ports are called 0102 as
specified in the wire
description
so this description of a graph
is not is none of the way that graph
works or the way that net graph works
i believe that is this idea of wires
am i confused here i mean so this is
this is giving a bunch of edges
correct no it isn't it's it's
but it's giving edges to ports it's
giving edges
that go not to nodes but to ports of
nodes
right right so so again in string
diagram writing you have the concept of
a true vertex sorry
okay you know the concept of a true
vertex versus the concept of a of a
dummy vertex
so dummy vertices for the most part are
treated just like ordinary vertices but
they have certain additional constraints
like you know
they have their obvious constraints on
the out degree
of a dummy vertex for instance
um so they obey almost the same
properties as an ordinary vertex but not
quite
in some sense charles can you talk about
this we've got tagged
edges right charles um yes
how does this relate to tagged
edges i mean in other words you say
i'm going to fill the ports of a node
i don't know what what do we have what
what information does a node have
it doesn't know about its edges right
all it knows
is it's a node it doesn't know
how many edges it's going to have the
edges are just filled in saying i go
from this node to that node
right um yeah in principle yes
it doesn't have any i mean
we don't associate any information to
the vertex but it's possible to do that
but we don't
so we still keep it you know completely
abstract that we have the vertex and the
edge
which is pretty much just that
it's the edge that is is declaring what
vertices it's associated with
it's not the vertex in any way saying i
expect the set of edges
right that's the difference i mean the
difference is we've got tags in the
edges
but we don't have any way in which
there's matching of those tags to
anything it's like a vertex could
declare
i expect edges with the following tags
in principle yes
we need to talk about this okay the
other thing that this is raising is
turning a graph into a function
because that's essentially both of these
are in a sense taking a graph
and
saying i mean just as net graph does net
graph is a generalization
of you know net graph is a bunch of
contractions basically these are all
well they're a bunch of contractions out
of products and contractions
and the question is
you know how would i get just like in in
for example in trees
now you can say tree fold
okay here's a question so tree fold
is an operation that takes a tree
and uses it to create a value of a
function
am i making sense
that makes sense to anybody
right so this tree fold here
it's a value not a function
it's like fault itself
no no i understand i understand but what
it's doing is
it is using this as raw material instead
of a list it's using a tree as raw
material
it's a evaluation but but it's not using
it as
uh right as an as
well i guess to a certain right it's not
using it as operations right it's
using it as pure inputs to the external
function f not
as representations of some operation
right we don't have
we don't have something which uses the
tree payload
to fill in the f's
right what i'm saying whereas here the
the graph payloads the node character
is filling in the functions here it's
not so much
but i think there's a generalization of
this idea
of you know just as we can evaluate a
function that is a chain
f of g of h this is the beginnings of
evaluating a function
that is where sort of the connectivity
is defined by a graph
does that make any sense to anybody
you know at before we did neural nets
tally and i had a proto design which i'm
sure i still have somewhere
for functions that would be
sort of graph put together if that makes
sense
is this making any sense to anybody
i mean to me this net graph
this etc they're all part of the same
story
they're all a graph defines a way in
which arguments of functions aka tensors
are knitted together i think
that is this this graph here forget that
the tensors have array elements
this graph here
represents you know
these edges could just be an inner
function this represents
an expression basically it represents an
expression where certain dummy variables
have been used
yeah i mean it's it's an expression as
jonathan is saying i didn't know they
were called this but but
um where there is a a
dummy vertex here that is being put in
so so in other words okay so i'm going
to make the claim
actually okay there's a simpler case of
this which is just dags
okay so let's imagine that we have the
expression
f of g of x comma y
comma well comma let's say
let's say g of x that's a good example
here
let's say
oh i don't know i don't know how to make
a good example of this my basic point is
here there are common sub expressions
here
and so there is a graph version of this
is it the case that what these things
are doing
is basically you could unroll them
well i'm not sure did anybody understand
and talking about whether you can
okay to what extent is this related to
the dag
representation of an expression i mean
we have the tree representational
expression
but what about the dag representation
where we're combining common
sub-expressions is that an example of
this type of thing
any thoughts i would argue
it's subtly different sorry go ahead go
ahead in what way
uh well i mean this is showing the
compositional structure not the
expression structure
right what's the difference
i mean composition means what's f of g
of x
is a composition isn't it sure but you
you're you're talking about
um sort of getting the dag
representation by looking at you know
common sub-expressions between
two parts or something yes which
okay maybe it's equivalent to the the
string diagram cases but if it is i
don't think it's a it's not an
equivalent i'm aware of
well but you could unroll it jonathan
it's a question of evaluation
right in in other words there could be
you could redo
you're saying there are two pieces that
have to be connected that they're
somehow the same as represented by the
string diagram
well um go ahead all i'm saying is that
the string diagram
what it's really representing is a
generalization of ordinary linear
function composition
right it's talking about okay we've got
uh
each of these generators is a it will in
general be a multi-input argument
multi-output argument
thing and they can and and those
functions can be applied either in
serial or in parallel
and that's what the string diagram is
showing it's showing you essentially how
those arguments get
fed between yeah okay so the big
difference
is that we don't normally have
multi-argument functions
the big difference here is this is the
beginning of representing
you know normally we have trees
we don't have things where there can be
multi we have trees that
that accumulate to a root
whereas a lot of these things whether
it's neural nets or other things
we have we have functions that basically
have multiple outputs
and in the case of a tree there's a much
more limited lexicon of ways that you
can knit
you know inputs and outputs together so
to speak
and and so i mean i think this is the
beginning of um
i mean i think this is a pretty general
issue of um
of representing sort of combinations of
functions
in such a way that in in a more general
way
and and to me you know we have graphs
the one thing we're lacking is graphs
with ports
the other thing we're lacking is an
evaluator for graphs so to speak
if i'm not mistaken i mean just like
this is the beginning of an evaluator
for trees
for example here's a question um well i
guess with expression tree
so if i took this and i say
tree expression of this i'm gonna get
some goofy thing
what the heck is that
it's uh it's a an issue with uh
uh it's a it's a known issue
don't don't get distracted by it okay
all right okay
but in a case look at what this did
this is essentially turning a tree into
an expression
imagine that we could turn a graph like
this into an expression
i think the reason that's tricky is a
piece of functional programming
stuff that we don't have which is
if right now this function is returning
a single thing
right whereas what we really want is
something where that function can return
multiple things and can be then plumbed
to different places
right and the only way we have to do
that right now
is really messy i mean we say you know x
y equals this and then we use
x and we use y somewhere i mean this is
a generalization
of the curry applied et cetera et cetera
et cetera story
this is a story of how things get
applied to things i think
jose is this making any sense to you i
think so
so in linear algebra we have
contractions of two
slots and we treat the two slots on the
same footing
because a function of a vector can be
also read
as the vector of the dual and so there
is this symmetry that we don't have in
in normal expressions in normal
expressions we always expect a clear
difference between the function and the
object
to which the function is applied yeah
okay
and also there's no it's not clear that
you have to have or maybe it's the
analog
maybe a graph corresponds to the the
pairwise contraction and it would have
to be a hypergraph to do the
non-pairwise contraction right there is
also the multi
case and and we have discussed recently
all these generalized contractions
and their multi-contractions and how to
express multi-contractions and things
like that
so linear algebra constructions are
always between two
slots only right okay
listen we should break this off to a
separate meeting but this is the the
meeting is about
you know ports and graphs string
diagrams generalized contractions tensor
networks maybe we should call it the
tensor network meeting
addison if that's for you um that's uh
yeah that's what we would need um the
uh okay did anybody
charles have any further comment i mean
we're not gonna handle this here but
i mean did charles have any further
comments he wants to quickly make about
ports
um no not at this time probably we'll
discuss that more in detail during the
meeting
okay fine all right let's move on okay
um oops
let me just save this somewhere
uh where am i saving it eek
where do i save these usually i guess i
save this to this functional
strange functional programming thing
yeah there's also
like an ild folder but that's fine okay
all right prime pi reporting
option report
oh it's just that we you know we did the
implementation of the progress reporting
before
actually i was aware that we have a
general dollar sign
progress reporting global variable so
it's just a basic update
there's no big issue here okay oh sander
has
put something on our live stream sanders
says congratulations on 12
3. thank you very much sander
much appreciated all right
the question is oh why does it not have
a remaining time
because you have no idea of time you
will take to compute
so this first you know the one stage of
the prime pie
where we do it you know first basic
computation
i mean from the grammar formula and at
some point we actually
know exactly the time which will be you
know we will need or
pretty much an estimate so
okay so look in this case with the
progress
reporting framework we need to say
unknown here this is completely obscure
what what's showing up here
in my view hey todd you want to comment
on that
just the fact that um
i i think we
um the fact that it just says time
remaining dot dot dot
yeah it's just very confusing it's as if
something what the heck is that
one m
look if it's counting in seconds i do
not understand why we don't just say one
colon oh seven
well uh there's
i mean arguably that that's ambiguous
uh right because that could mean an hour
and seven years well i mean
it's ambiguous if you don't see it
counting up in seconds
right uh i'm the slightest bit ambiguous
if you see it counting
right so if it's going to be counting i
think we should use this
okay i
yeah i mean i think it's using some
general
function that that people are using you
know some
time to readable string
function that so um whoa
but we can dig into that okay uh
remaining
uh
make sure to make a note of this for the
next progress reporting meeting
okay i think this should say per an
unknown
totally obscure otherwise
yeah i don't think unknown is quite
right but
it's what's the word i'm looking for i
feel like we've
encountered this before and we came up
with a better word um
but yeah like uh me este you know
estimating time but we can't
we don't know i mean you know if this is
like how long is it going to take the
turing machine to halt
it's like we just have no idea really no
idea
yeah okay next question is is there any
way we could say what it's doing
i guess that's a question for charles
to say um yes we know what he's doing
but you mean
i'm not sure that information will be
useful to
anyone unless you know the algorithm or
what's actually running behind well give
me
give me a sense of what it would say
what could it say lemurizing
not very helpful i don't know but you go
go ahead but i don't think it matters
that people don't know what it is
because they're really curious
they go search for it and they find out
what that is
i mean the first version we actually had
the you know
you know we had actually an answer which
actually tell you the method you know we
are using and from that method there is
you know it's essentially
like you know like you know it's
pampered if it's an asymptotic term
and then there is the main term so is
that you know that mean term
computation we first do before we start
to estimate the synthetic part
so you know
well then charles look to me
even if the things are somewhat
complicated i mean you know the fact is
you just launched your computer doing
something it's you know the fact that
it's doing something fancy that you
don't understand
is irrelevant it still gives you some
idea
the creature is not dead
right i mean at the time there was one
suggestion which you know we usually see
that in
you know pretty much all software you
have a you know is
a bar you know moving know we progress
by moving around and you know which kind
of statue that the whole thing is
computing
oh it's you know yeah yeah that's what
this is doing but we're asking for
something which gives more information
about what it's doing
it's the whole point we've already got
the bar this is the bar
here it is right we're asking for a
string that says what it's doing
right and what's the resistance to
giving that string that we don't know
what to i mean
if the string how many different strings
in in this prime pi computation
how many different stages does it go
through
um well i'll just presume that it goes
coffee to three stage
so we can pretty much tell the different
stage
then we should do it then we should do
that okay can any of those stages have
their times predicted
um except the first one where it is
actually but the
remaining one yeah we know the time then
why aren't we saying remaining time blah
because we're still in stage one i
presume yep
right so like uh um
uh the uh export to
video does something kind of similar
right
look what's this what's this what's this
so now we have an idea of the
time so we have you know
well i'm surprised that there hasn't
that the remaining time hasn't updated
yeah there we go
cute an estimated time anyway too right
so
hopefully not be five hours yeah it's
generally an overestimate
but uh there you go
um right and so the
um the video export
right has a similar problem where it
doesn't know how long it will take to
sort of prepare the frames for export so
it says
you know preparing frames for export
with
some sort of indefinite and no estimated
time and then it says
you know exporting frames and then it
has the progress bar with the estimate
so it does something similar it just
adds a little bit of text like that so
i presume prime pie could do something
similar okay
listen the basic point is it is
information to say it doesn't yet know
how much time it will take
right should it say like tbd
that's too obscure um
remaining time paren not yet known
that seems reasonable not yet known in
parens
because the whole point is you think oh
why doesn't it know how long it's going
to take well i'm sorry it just doesn't
know yet
you see what i'm saying
yep that seems
you know seems useful and and here
i mean honestly i'm much less interested
in the method
by the time i'm seeing the progress bar
my interest in what it's doing just you
know just imploded basically
although i still wouldn't mind seeing a
string saying what it's doing
but i really don't like these ms things
by the way
okay i mean tv on the livestream's
asking can all functions compute their
time complexity
profoundly no profoundly profoundly no
um i was gonna say it also probably
doesn't
need to report three granularities
two's probably enough at any given time
oh no let's give the seconds give the
second it's okay so the nine hours 27
minutes and 15 seconds
it's fine okay it shows the animal is
alive
right and it's overly precise but you
know so what wow are we actually going
to get a result but see what happens
here
yeah and right and in which case i'm
going to complain about being in a
nine-hour meeting
aren't there labor laws against that
sort of thing right
no but well congratulations to the prime
pie
um
do we object to the fact that time
remaining was an estimate that was wrong
i think no
yeah you're always pleasantly surprised
when it's it's faster
right i agree so i don't think we should
follow i think right
right and also if it tells you two
minutes and it turns into three minutes
that's annoying but fine if it tells you
two minutes and then
it turns into three hours then people
will be pretty annoyed so
right that's the case to avoid right
right look i do think if there are
strings i think it'll be a good test
case charles if you could make up
candidate strings
that would represent the stages let's
look at them and see whether we think
that they're reasonable
okay i can't do that i'm not sure i've
ever seen the time estimate on an os
update be correct
right
yeah well fair enough and that's much
simpler
than what we're doing here um okay
let's let's move on here um
okay so so the next uh couple of agenda
items are
are potentially related so it might be
worth
thinking about them together um
so one is coming from michael and i
think there's a bit more context that
maybe he wants to provide but it
basically is
right subscripted variables
right they're considered functions of
the the the main variable um
[Music]
and uh you know
and so you know i understand i
understand so so there are several
related things
there's the famous x sub one
blank story as you might recall
no probably nobody here recalls this
version three we were going to put this
in we had it almost all designed
i remember it was a 10 hour design
meeting in the end
and in the end i said we're just not
going to figure this out we should give
it we got to give up
right so that's the next question is
maybe michael was involved in i can't
remember
but um
you know the issue is to symbolize it
right right well what did we want to do
i mean we want to
i think we wanted it was clear how to do
it in the 400 but it wasn't clear
unclear how to do symbolize something in
the
evolution sequence
i see what you say so you're saying the
issue is
we want our sub one you know basically
what we want to do is pack it into a
symbol and then be able to unpack it
it wants to walk and talk like a symbol
until such time as you say well what
really was inside there
no actually for most cases we never want
to look inside
which you might ask someone
so to speak but we could then we could
use symbol name or something to look
inside
right so the issue is you know
is there a way to say our sub one
and to simplify it i mean we're now
20 however many years later we should be
able to do
this now we've got all this money
yeah it's not just a matter to be able
to
do this say like in a vain environment
out sub one it shouldn't need additional
work to saying
r sub 1 is not a transcendental
dependence on r
because nobody would ever ever think of
r sub 1 in this manner
i understand but i understand that f f
sub x as being function of x
right in fact uh people might think of f
sub x as the derivative of f with
respect to x
right well okay fair enough but but
there's several different issues here
one is
can we use subscripted variables as
pattern variables that's one thing
second is
are they you know under what
circumstances is
r sub one for purposes of solve for
example just a black box blob
right and let me point out that you know
we we have literally dozens of
such things right we have subscript
superscript sub superscript
over script over bar superstar
yeah i could go on i know we do we have
a bunch of typesetting constructs the
question is
should a typesetting construct be
considered a black box thing
and i have to say i would have thought
that that would be the natural
assumption
and we never did that you know we've had
these types of constructs since version
three
but we've never done it that way let's
say reversely under which circumstances
could we ever do something non-trivial
with it
because we can't do inverse function of
subscript
it makes no mathematical meaning
and i'm starting to get worried about
bessel j
because you can differentiate with
respect to the index and that sort of
thing but your point is
that then you would be using bustle j
and not
j subscript if you use
j subscript you don't get a better
function yeah you don't get anything
exactly exactly no bustle at all yeah
uh you might in traditional form yeah
but that's a different thing it's got
interpretation boxes and so on it's not
an issue
yeah i don't think i don't think that's
true
right i mean certainly you can type in
lowercase sign
in traditional form and and well if if
you start with bezel and you ask for its
traditional form then yes it'll give you
a template box
but the question is is there if if you
do like
j sub something introdu and interpret it
in traditional form what will it do
and maybe we only did that for the trig
and inverse trig functions
but um
wow in traditional form it does auto
bracket matching how nice
wow that's a big disclaimer
what do you know okay but but this is a
weird weird case
i'm i'm amazed that that works
and what we do in traditional form is so
different from what we do generally it
doesn't matter
just doesn't matter well i mean that
that
right i mean you took the output right
and then you and
put it into an input cell no no no i
didn't you weren't watching i typed this
yeah okay that was typed but but but
then i think our point is now it's not a
subscript expression it's a bessel j
expression
yes okay
so let's discuss the possibility
that all typeset constructs become
essentially black boxes
for purposes of essentially mathematical
operations
and potentially i mean what happens if i
say
table
yeah well that's not number oh that did
work
i love that okay
and but this oh well i
yes although i think it's i think that's
in
[Music]
this is going to really wig out yes
i have to say that i don't think i mean
maybe we need a more careful analysis
um
but i'm kind of wondering why we don't
make these type setting constructs
able to be used to make
as if black box objects
i mean okay so here's a weird case okay
let's say i do d
of subscript you know x squared plus one
comma you know min or something
i don't even know what the heck that did
that's just totally freaking
weird well it's giving you the partial
derivative
of subscribers it's an unknown functions
to to all mathematical
functions so subscript is not no
different than f
all right so look the thing i'm
imagining
is there are two levels of this
okay this blanks thing is a different
issue
perhaps so is the module thing a
different issue
but in terms of the mathematical
operations i
just think it should be treated as a as
a blob of a black box
convince me otherwise well it'll
so how how would this work like would
freak you say that
that subscript of x one is free of x or
or we have to add special treatment for
substitute to ever to every mathematical
function
have to add special treatment right
which
could be really you know really
i think we need to inventory for
performance cost
right i mean dc right you know
inputs to solve can be you know
hundreds of equations yeah how many
how many backwards and compatibilities
do we get uh
if we if suddenly subscript and friends
are atomic
which would cause them to be free q of
their arguments
oh that would be that i i imagine that
actually that would
be horrible that would be terrible yeah
okay so a question would be and by the
way what does system modeler do with
subscripted variables it has a whole
subscripted variable
circus doesn't it
anybody here know about that
why is this slow typing again
why is this happening i thought that was
fixed
that that this thing is not typing at
full speed in the in this
search box
that's for addison to go poke at again
shouldn't be happening and somebody mark
down the time stamp here
you can go see it happening get it
okay
okay i don't know
this is showing anything here let's see
oh boy well this doesn't happen to show
anything without me just see in this
case
where are they they're just equations
with just tons of subjects
i think in this i think there is never
really a
problem because there you only have the
subscripted one and the subscripted one
themselves
are used you don't have this r1 and r2
scenario you have to r1 r2 r3 to rn
scenario and then you can solve for the
compound
i'm sorry what oh i see you're saying
solving for all the r sub i's it's no
problem
right then what case r is a variable
also
i'm very confused what are you talking
about the are you talking about system
or are you talking about the more
general case like like in the system
model scenario
you say have some state and the state is
some vector x and x 1
to x 20 but you never have as
individual x additionally floating
around right i mean
right so so it's right so if if we took
the
the the solve output with one over r and
instead of
solving for r right we called it uh
you know one over little r say and solve
for little r there wouldn't be any
problem
and you could also s solve for the
script of r one or subscript of r two
it's
when you mix a subscripted and
non-subscripted variable that you
get into trouble
which are which especially this
differential equation example for the
down choice people do very frequently
that they say y of 0 is by 0. that's
very common
right right so i'm coming back to my
statement why can't we treat
all these typesetting constructs as
black boxes
as symbol-like things for purposes of
mathematical functions
and it i raised some performance issue
which i
don't really believe but but we can
address how i might deal with that
but other than that is it the case that
like let's imagine that there was
a symbol representation of all
subscripted objects
okay and let's imagine that somehow and
that that's what was used if you wanted
to make
r sub one blank
i mean and let's imagine that
the preprocessor for equations turned
all these things into the symbol-like
representation of the subscripts
did the equation solving and then turn
them back
right it could just replace them with
you new variable the
is it but but it would be a performance
hit for for
every equation you you or every system
i'm rolling my eyes because i just don't
believe in this product
but but it could be maybe restricted to
the case when it doesn't work
when everything works fine then don't do
it if it doesn't work then try again
and do more work
i don't know i don't think that's some
uh
well maybe look the performance thing is
nonsense i mean we can solve that piece
of engineering
if if you really think that's an issue
let's go let's think about solving that
piece of engineering
the okay so the issue is how to scan the
expression
to get all the typesetting constructs
i'm sure there are ways to do that
with some of our internal hashing stuff
and so on
that i'm just certain there's a way to
do that efficiently
right we do that for dsor actually
anyway we have some scanning to
replace which looks suspect for the
later solvers so
we replace them with new model variables
um
the only issue that we someone need to
know where to look so we look in the
dependent variable list
to figure out what what's worth
replacing
you would have to scan the whole
equation so if you have
like thousand by thousand system of
linear equations
you would have to scan the whole system
to see if if it contains subscript
you know what you're not gonna sell me
on a performance it may may not be i
actually it would have to be much sorry
to measure it
it's just not gonna be an issue right
you're solving a thousand by thousand
symbolic collection of matrices of
equations
this will not be an issue well numeric
numeric will have the same problem if
you
you want and solve to have the same okay
fine
i'm telling you there's a way to do this
with hashing or some other method
yeah we can figure it out it's it's may
or may not be a problem it would have to
be measured right but so i can tell you
for a start
to know that there are no subscripts in
the expression
is very fast so we're out of the game
in that case if you set the thing up
with subscripts
better that it work in finite time then
it not work at all
so i i just that it's not going to be an
argument so let's talk about the
semantics
of what it can do okay so the question
is
if what happened is every one of this
list of typesetting constructs
turned itself into an as if symbol
in which any content
was just invisible right and it can do
that in a variety of ways it could do
that by putting a wrapper around it
it can do that i don't know you know
right now you're probably using
free q to look inside are you is that
right yeah yeah so so it it would have
to just replace it with
with a variable like generate new symbol
and replace it with
new symbol of x1 through xn or something
different possibility
you could not use freeq you could use a
new free queue
right everywhere inside
i don't know i don't care this is a
stupid software engineering claim
okay if it's a question of you know
yes the code is going to have to be
changed that's what happens when we
change
the functionality right and
you know it may be much more efficient
and more sensible to change free cue
than to go pre-processing every
expression is that the only is that the
single place where
it finds out that the thing has the
variable inside well i think
i mean there's the other question of you
know what if it's subscript of y
comma x
what well okay that's a question what we
wanted to do in that case
right i mean i think
um what do we want it to do in that case
i think it's tough luck
i don't think that's a function of x
anymore
so you're saying treat that as a new
constant
that i think dependent of both y and x
i think so so are we making a decision
on behalf of the user that
we say this is constant whereas the user
kind of indicates some variable
dependence i'm just
only my only worry is that that we can
do it but
it's going to do it then we're kind of
assuming that the user meant that is
that
safety okay another i mean
maybe one possibility is you know
we have a new option like opaque heads
goes to automatic
and so subscript
and whatever other typesetting guys go
into that and if people
don't want that they can you know they
make it empty list and if they
want to add their own custom ones
then they can add those right i think
the question is the default why sub x
i don't know i'm not sure about that i
worry about it
because i can think of a case you know
what's a good
y sub i oh no no y sub
uh let's say y sub min you're unlikely
to have something
you know y sub min probably means
you don't want it to be a function of
min right
yeah now y sub s
for some reason i'm thinking that um
that's less clear to me is that a
constant
or is that a function of s
you know y sub i yeah actually y sub i
is a great example
y sub i could mean the initial r y
or it could mean y that is somehow
implicitly a function of x
of i sorry do you get what i'm saying
yeah so what do we do with a case like
that
okay so we have this and
i think it's going to wind up having to
have a wrapper i i think that the
the question of what the default is i
mean i tend to think
that the default should be
okay let me give an example so if i have
let's say we do this let's say we say
um okay so here's a weird case all right
so let's say we say
solve x squared equals 4
x with x with respect to x and now i
take that x there
and i make it
um
i make it red okay
kaboom it ignores yeah well that's i
mean that's an irrelevant example
because the kernel never sees the red
the front end strips the red before it
ever sends anything to the kernel
look the fact that y sub i is a typeset
construct
not a thing
well okay let's okay my tendency i agree
with that i that that having an option
that determines how these subscripted
things are handled
is a clear escape valve for that
the thing that i'm still interested in
is is there a way to solve the
x y sub i blank problem
i i think that's a bigger i know but
maybe we can solve it at the same time
um i mean the question there is
look actually okay here's the obvious
solution to that
here's the obvious solution the os
solution is in the parser
if you type x sub i blank
simply you know in 25 years ago we were
afraid of doing something like that
but in other words to basically change
it syntactically
to just be a symbolized x sub one
right which suggests to me that we need
something which says you know if we say
symbol
how does this work we say symbol quotes
x right we get x
if i say symbol x sub 1
quotes x splaferu
right there's no good reason that
shouldn't work
the symbol table shouldn't care i mean
so long as it's canonical
the symbol table shouldn't care whether
what it has in it
is i mean i think we were afraid of of
linear syntax and things at the time
so i'm saying that that in my opinion
should work and what should happen is
no i think okay good we've gotten better
at design in 25 years
i think what we should do in a case like
this is that the
parser should turn that into symbol
of x1 a symbol of r1
an actual symbol
and how flexible is that could i have a
you know symbol of an unevaluated
integral right i mean
[Music]
you should be able to do that but but i
already realized the problem with this
it's all well and good to do that in the
past but what about the right hand side
right if i say f of
x i blank
colon equals x i
you know squared oops
how do i make that work
okay so the other possibility is that
the pattern
object that is x sub i
blank could take something other than a
symbol on its left-hand side
right but what you have on the
right-hand side it doesn't have pattern
in it right
so i think but this
is look this is this is the same
x this thing here right is
pattern x comma blank right
why do you think there's a problem no
i'm just saying that the name
of the the name of the object is x sub i
okay and what happens if there there's
this
x and an i on the right hand side
you mean you're saying they're
irrelevant
those are no more visible as being like
x sub i i mean
in other words gosh it would be nice to
solve this problem
it's been a long time
i think this well let's see okay
you know the third the final problem is
the module variable
problem
i mean module variable i think is you
know to me feels like it ought to be the
easiest of them
because it's lexically scanned anyway
and i mean it literally does a
replacement
i know so you know it's just a different
replacement
right but the question is i think so i
forget who is just raising that
is how general can it be is it just
subscripted variables with subscript and
so on
are we treating those now as as
semantically significant
i think that would be pretty adequate i
mean you know the set of variables that
i've needed
that are you know annotated variables
it's a very definite annotation list
you know it's things like overbar
well okay i mean so the thing is is that
in addition to subscript
you have a lot of people who you know
because they work in text editors or
whatever
don't use subscript they use x bracket
one brackets
okay well that's tough luck i mean then
they're not using
it's tough luck we can't deal with that
i mean that's a different thing that
that's
that's the question of what the default
behavior here is
i mean for example that's a different
question which is a perfectly reasonable
question
of what happens if you say solve x
sub 1 squared plus
x squared equals 1 with respect to x sub
1.
okay that was fine now what happens if i
say solve with respect to x
okay how did that work guys oh the
free q doesn't is false by default
so it doesn't find the x in the head
that's extremely fragile really oh or
are you saying that free q is setting
heads goes to false
no which is not its default you say
freak
yeah the member q defaults aheads goes
to false
freak you okay but so
so what has been revealed here
yeah heads goes to false it'll do that
what has been revealed adam
is that were we to add an option to free
q
your claim you could just ins you are
already using free q it heads to false
i'm using let's press lit in the c code
which might have a different setting for
for default
whatever right but but whatever but i
mean in in um
uh okay but the fundamental point is
that we could as well have a setting to
freak you which will be interesting
which is don't go inside subscript and
so on
right we could say you know i don't know
what it would be called you know
right but i ignored i don't think we
could possibly change the default values
no
no absolutely not absolutely not but we
could certainly document
that these mathematical functions are
effectively using freeq with that option
i'm making sense yeah that's a
possibility
right
there might be some implementation
problems like you know
i don't care yeah no i think it works
yeah if you're an option then we can
globally have a new internal function
which does exactly that option setting
once and then everyone is picks up you
know so guys
guys if you do a fine software engineers
you can solve this yes
absolutely it's not difficult i agree um
the okay sandra is commenting on on
using head exclusions in free queue
yes something like that is probably
right um
but but if we did this then
we would solve the problem of the math
functions
you know burrowing inside these things
right
so that would solve that problem now we
still have the two outstanding problems
as far as i'm concerned
of uh you know
x min blank
and um
what's the other one and the um and the
module variables
right right but but yeah right well okay
well what about
block
does block work with x someone right now
i think it does
uh uh no it requires symbols
okay why is block any different
well it's a signing i see it's assigning
values
okay yeah that's complicated
um look solving this for the math
functions will be a good start but i
really think we should
as part of this lcc series we should
readdress this question about
about some pattern variables okay
um but let's investigate this free q
modification
to deal with the math functions and that
i think would solve michael's problem is
that true
yeah great
right just just don't necessarily expect
it for 13 because i don't see this being
a project i mean it might
but yeah we certainly can't promise that
without
you know once we're significantly
further along in development
um craig is making a comment about
matrix form and it's a good it's a good
and interesting comment and let's look
at what he's saying
so the main issue is given a matrix
you know that was beautifully formatted
you know i do so love this
this auto matching thing
how we could have survived without order
matching in the past i have no idea
okay so now we say inverse of this
why do of course that works never mind
that would the problem would be and
thinking of this
that will also work the pro
because uh of the tag box structure
tells it to remove the matrix form
the problem you get into is when you say
a equals matrix form of blah
and then you try
inverse of xx
right because that when you refer to
percent
right that right the out uh says slash
matrix form so out removes okay i've got
a comment here
one of the things that's a slippery
slope that we have slid down
in these years is differentiating
inactivated things
but there was a time when if it didn't
have the right form you didn't do
anything to it
see what i'm saying if i say you know
inactive
if i say inactive bessel j
you know 0x okay
in the past we just said you're out of
luck it's not going to differentiate
it's going to give some weird thing but
now
we are differentiating through the
inactive
making sense i mean technically we added
an active and a differentiation rule at
the same time i mean
i mean you couldn't have asked this
question before we had the capability to
do it
right so the question is why are we not
doing matrix operations through matrix
form
that's a very good solution because
we've been struggling with that or you
change the type setting but i think the
easiest solution is just to allow matrix
form inside
uh linear algebra operations so then if
you say
right well yes and no i mean i don't
think plus wants to be in the business
of
i mean if you're talking about inverse
and debt maybe
but i don't think plus wants to be in
the business of so how could you make
that distinction
well that's part of the problem right
i was going to ask sparse array of
matrix form
or yeah it's pass away of matrix form or
splash array of
what what's wrong with that it's going
to be called
it's not it's not a linear algebra
function okay but but
why not okay question okay so
for plus okay plus is listable
why isn't plus also i mean okay so the
the problem that would arise is
you have a matrix form thing you add you
know you say plus one
the thing blows itself out and it now
returns lists
right
so you might say that's bad because you
started off with a matrix form and you
ended up with lists
on the other hand it's probably even
worse that it is dumb as a stone and
doesn't do anything
i mean
to ask a radical question what will be
wrong with having matrix form be
essentially listable
or some version of lustable some
analogue of listable
well then it wouldn't work right because
it would evaluate
i get it i understand it can't be it
can't be
outside in listable it could be
such that it is transparent with respect
to listability
uh that that would be a question for rob
i mean conceptually
uh i i mean right we do have a couple
right so sparse array
is an exception and structured and
structured array is an exception so i
guess the question is
could we add matrix form and maybe also
table form i'm not sure or do or
do we really think matrix form is much
more i'm not sure about that that's a
that's a
further issue um
but you know i think i asked rob the
question
right and then the second issue would be
can we make the
you know the obvious things that
think they're eating matrices except
matrix form
right well i guess one of the question
is
um right so like inverse right it's
it quietly sits there until it
receives an actual matrix which allows
you to write things like
inverse of a and and do things
absolutely right
and so the question is this isn't going
to cause a problem with that
it's not going to this isn't a
masquerading a symbolic
thing right so you're saying only a
matrix form
that contains an actual matrix inside of
it
would yes a matrix form that is matrix
form of
a or something just like whatever i
don't know what to do with that
and should it preserve it so inverse of
a matrix form should it be a matrix form
too that would be lovely
let us investigate this this is a good
idea we should this is one of those kind
of
ridiculous you know trip up things
that's been there for
for you know forever yes at least now
it's properly documented ian and i about
a year ago
you know actually clarified all these
there were so many bug reports that you
know we went in and
updated the documentation so it's
actually
clarifies what the behavior is fair
enough
but okay i think it's a good thank you
craig for that for
pushing us when you were working on some
of the matrix
the linear algebra docs recently yep
were you using matrix form
for like you know matrix form of some
particular matrix plus
matrix form of some other particular
matrix to
do sort of pretty looking arithmetic
no i never did that i would i might do
something like
open paren a equals
math close paren matrix form
so the original input looks pretty and
then i
do a plus whatever or you know
operation of course that's partly
because i know about this
issue and so i didn't want you know to
have wrong
examples um and and so i
wrote my code in such a way um but
you know i i'll be doing more cleanup of
the linear algebra pages 413
so um i could i could think a little bit
about
i mean on some level i don't really want
you know i suppose if it's two by two or
three by three but even then you know
matrix form can pretty quickly eat up a
lot of space so it's not necessarily
such a nice thing to put in an input
it's great for the for the output but
the input is not
so nobody knows how to type it it's a
mess
right all right this is a really good
thing
let's bring it back for another meeting
go ahead what are you gonna say
oh okay all right let's move on to the
formal operator's question
yeah i will point out that it is 5 30
um and this is so we should wrap up soon
but let's just take a quick look at this
um
my gosh what is all of this stuff
okay i think the relation here is that
in the previous meeting you were
suggesting a wrapper
around say alpha
sorry a formal b form to have a symbolic
a b and things like that so we thought
that it might be related with
subscript x1 sorry i'm sorry what is
this
about this is this is about the issue is
you know how symbolic is symbolic at
some level
like for example you know we want to
have an axiomatic theory
that is um are we getting we're going to
get a whole bunch of new ones aren't we
isn't that does anybody know about that
try field actions
for example in which we have we are
using now a tilde instead of an equal
so one of the ideas was how do we
introduce a nice
new equal there which is not the
standard one
a we were looking for formal plus and
formal a b
things like that i think we should have
those i mean why don't we just use dots
why don't we just go ahead uh
right well uh
i mean that that was jose's idea and you
thought that was too limited you thought
there was a much more general issue and
wanted this big discussion which is why
what was that okay so jose's idea was
just have a class of
new symbols just like we have formal
letters of the alphabet to have formal
things for our various infix operators
right formal equals
so those things would have
how would they parse like
equals will be a binary operator yes
well i guess we could make it uh
a formal equals uh a binary no but it
has to be something
right because it's the whole point well
our our uh
well our normal equals is not binary
right it's n
airy oh i see i see it i i wasn't even
thinking about that point but from a
pausing point of view
i don't even know how the positive does
it what does the parser do if i say
a equals equals b equals equals c then
whole form
does it for a yeah it also flattens okay
so clearly it should not auto flatten
the formal equals clearly should not
auto flatten
okay
and honestly you know it's a little
weird because we're going to have
everything you know formal element
formal this form all that
what what properties from the original
one does the formal
part have right and for for example uh
right equal and less and less equal
all have the same precedence and if you
mix them right you get this inequality
thing that
you know preserves the flatness so if if
if
these guys are not flat then they're
going to parse differently
maybe we don't need a formal less equal
maybe we only need a formal equal
but well who knows if we need a formal
less equal i mean that you know we're
doing
lattice theory or something don't we
need a formal
okay the problem is this even the
pausing
might be wrong in the formal okay that's
this is a question i
i looked at this back in version three
okay the big surprise
was that even of these things that are
used only formally like circle plus
the pausing precedence was surprisingly
consistent am i making sense
that as you look at random formulas in
mathematical logic
people do not have different implicit
precedences of operators
between different formulas mostly
anybody want to comment jonathan do you
want to comment on that
i mean that that sounds right
but it's not self-evidently correct
because i mean these these operators
might mean very different things to very
to different people but that was my
observation at the time
um
yeah sandra is commenting that formal
the word formal has never been used
yeah i i know actually it was sort of
being reserved
and
the problem is that if you say formal as
a rapper it's already too late i mean
so so let's take a formula that we want
to be sort of formalizable
okay so predicate logic jonathan give me
some predicate logic thingy dingy
here let's say not oops
not be
okay let's let's imagine we're dealing
with that and we just want it to be
completely formal
we don't want the not that we all know
see okay let's zoom out for a second
in terms of symbols we have had the
convention that things that start with
capital letters
how could have a built-in meaning
whereas things that don't couldn't
right that convention has stood us in
good stead for 35 years
right we do not have a similar
convention
because operators have special parsing
i mean i think i had discussed before
the possibility
okay okay here's a crazy possibility
okay i'm going to give you another crazy
idea
oh no it's too crazy okay
the idea was this imagine that we had a
bigger keyboard which had some special
character on it
just like we have escape for example
right now okay
do that all right imagine that
and this is kind of crazy but imagine
that
before you type you know you type a and
normally you get an ordinary a
but to get a formal a how do you get a
formal a do you say dot a
yes
so escape got a escape which is clearly
you know four characters instead of one
and then escape dot equals
turns into that or great well dot double
equals
doesn't mean anything so at the very
least in terms of
it just seems so weird i mean you know
we could certainly have a utility
function
that will take okay look this would be a
kind of
uh oh yeah this is an interesting idea
okay i've got an
idea to formal expression
okay so i type in here
i type a plus b equals equals c
okay but this says to formal expression
and so that instead of
pausing it with the normal parser where
a means a
it pauses it with the you know the
formal variable parser where that means
a dot
and plus means plus dot
what what does it do if you have a a
what do you mean if you if you have if
you have this a a variable here
yep ah
well
somebody should mute themselves well the
sorry uh but the uh right and i mean the
other problem is
what happens when uh right so that
equals
assuming we're using our parser that
equals was going to be flat
or we'd need to write a new parser which
is almost exactly the same as ours but
somehow
creates equals and a few other things
that's not flat
well the issue is flattening is that
true or is there any other operation
that is done
i mean the precedence we believe in the
same
how disastrous for mathematical logic
would it be to make equals b flat
anybody have any idea jonathan anybody
else pretty disastrous
for how we have things set up right now
because it's a binary operator right now
right so the the theorem prover can't
deal with um
operators of variable arity
which is which is why it causes so much
problem so many problems when we use
like boolean logic
um operators and things because you know
and is flat
well why don't we just why don't we just
make the theorem prover
go and you know bunch them up into
binaries
i mean it could
uh but then i mean that would
essentially have that would involve us
having to tell the theorem prover
explicitly which operators
should and shouldn't be d flattened was
the only reason for not doing it again
well hold on if the theorem prover okay
we know the operator and is not
the theorem prover can't handle nre and
today
maybe one day it can but the innards of
the theorem prover could just if it sees
a ternary and
it could just turn the the ternary and
into a binary you know into a pair of
binary atoms
why would it not do that otherwise it's
dead in the water
and it knows it's an and well go ahead
the the flattening occurs before the
kernel even sees it
that's part of the problem yeah but
should should equal be flat
like a equal b in parenthesis equals c
is not the same as
a equal b equals c
well that's that's that's just that
that's not going to be
that's not going to parse flat
right if you look at the i mean you can
see from the formatting but also if you
look at the full form you'll see that
that's an equal of equal
yeah right that's a different thing the
issue is
the issue is this case a equals b equals
c because
our equal is nra
right that but wait a second jonathan
hold on a second
you're saying that i mean the
mathematical logic case
is it parenthesized what's this supposed
to mean in the mathematical logic case
what on earth does this mean
well presumably it would have it would
have to have some default associativity
no no but i'm just like rule right i
mean right if you do a
arrow b arrow c right you'll get a rule
of rule
sure sure sure no but i'm asking
jonathan if he's saying
you know deductive inference rules for
equation of logic a equals b
equals c would be positive to a equals b
and b equals c and then you'd use the
association you use the transitivity
property of the equivalence relation to
handle the rest
okay so this one here why is this giving
a little twitch when i move over this
something was twitching there did you
see that
did people see that oh i'm not saying it
over zoom but it might be
i mean if you're if you actually click
in between right it's going to tear them
apart
because right there because of the oh
that's
new yes it's new right
that's right so as a cursor as you
cursor through compound
operators then you see the individual
bits in case you need
to change one of them wow well you know
all
many unintended consequences okay never
mind
i'm i'm not i'm not unhappy about that i
was just surprised
um okay so jonathan is saying
this thing should turn into equal a
equals b
and b equals c well why don't we just do
that in the
in the theorem prover no
we we we could but um the point i was
making was just this is part of this
more general problem which is
you know essentially the front-end
flattening
stuff before the theorem prover even
sees it and it seemed like we needed a
general solution to that problem but
hold on equals
okay the question is what's in the sort
of metal logic and what's in the actual
formal thing because are you saying that
equals
is at some level of metal logic or
something is that right
equality i mean you can treat equality
in two different ways right
in the equation logic theorem prover
you're treating it as
as a meta thing in the predicate logic
theorem prover i believe you're treating
it as just another predicate is that
true
this is true but from a pure logic
standpoint there's no difference between
the two that's a theorem
implementational detail
but in a case like field axioms we
cannot use the true equal because there
is a rule saying
a equals a we cannot let that evaluate
well we certainly can't let it evaluate
but if we had an equal the issue here is
what about the pausing
right so right now okay let's just
understand
a dotted equal a formal equal what rules
does it
what rules both does it have
by the way i do like this approach i
mean maybe people think this is crazy
but i do like this
as a way to not have the incredible pain
of entering you know a lot of guttiness
in it
what do other people think about that
well the question is how would that then
format
and also how how easy is it
to see as you're typing that you're
making mistakes typing into a string
it makes it seem like the right thing
would be a control equals like form for
formal expressions
right if we had a thing that was you
know control something or other
for why is that asymmetric why or why or
why is that asymmetric
is what asymmetric well there's more
there's more of a vertical line below
the equals than above oh
i see and yeah addison report it for 150
magnification some goofball thing there
got it um
i pasted something in chat that may or
may not be
okay and then do release hold of that
right so this splitting apart things
into ends is something we do via
evaluation and it's just so
so happens that with equal well we don't
know
if if we have a single operator right
because if you if you had right
if both of those less that right if both
of those inequalities were in the same
direction right it would stay as a
single
less than say right so it's only in the
case
we've made the decision that if there's
only one operator we keep it as
a big thing and then if there are
multiple ones then we split it into the
end
but there's nothing preventing the
theorem prover from deciding it wants to
you know split things up if it wants to
but jonathan but the problem is okay the
thing can never hit evaluation
the question is what properties okay
several points first of all although it
feels very heavyweight for something
that seems to us today
a bit obscure the concept of a control
equals like thing to enter formal
expressions
where we still have syntax coloring
going on seems like a not totally crazy
idea
comments from people worried that it
might want to
formalize too much we may have objects
there that
should then be formalized like what
like equal signs some
other variables we are using from a site
okay
well okay so that's a fair point right
like how do we how would we deal with
the case as we have in the field
accidents where you have two
equals operator two equality predicates
one of which is formal one which is not
oh
god
okay let's zoom out for a second what is
really going on here
what's really going on here is we have
both the quotes logic
the language of the logic and we have a
meta logic is that correct
and the operators of the metal logic are
real and evaluate things
and the the operators in the quotes
logic
that we are sort of playing around with
with predicate calculus and so on
is not is that correct jonathan
uh yes except they're not
operators in metal logic as metalogic is
conventionally defined
it's simply that there's a distinction
between operators that are defined
algebraically through an equational
theory and operators that are defined
sort of programmatically via the theorem
prover
well explain to me why that isn't metal
logic by the way
because the metal logic is the deduction
rules not not the equality
things and so on right
okay but there are things that are
structural
i mean implies is that part of
implies is something that is not down at
the level of the predicates that are
being
tossed around symbolically implies is
something at a higher level correct
well actually no in in the theorem
prover it isn't
um i know in the equation because you
have an equation logic theorem
everything is just being turned into
predicates right everything
except the equality right the the the
one operator that's different
is equality um that is what that's the
one that's defined
just in terms of the the algorithm um
there's nothing but now
in in in ordinary just so i understand
in what is even the name of it i mean
it's modus ponens based
deduction the implication is special
and equality is not special is that
correct right yeah so in in the second
calculus
um implication or semantic entailment is
the distinguished operator whereas an
equational calculus
equality is the distinguished operator
all right so
the claim is that there
are deduction rules there is something
that is used for the deduction rules
there's something that in our world is
the edges of the multi-way graph
is that correct yeah you can think of it
that way
which could be entailment or it could be
equality
or whatever so i mean in a sense what we
have is
is the the edges of the multi-way graph
are unlabeled
are untagged because we only have
because in any given thing it's either
secret calculus
or it's or it's some equational calculus
equational logic
whatever that's called
etc but but so in other words the the
edges of what is entailed
what entails what are just we fix that
once and for all
for any one of these things that we're
dealing with is that true statement
right and so so and those operators in
the current way that we set the thing up
those operators are not formal so like
when we do predicate logic they're
improving the implies is not formal
right well the equality is not false so
if you wanted to
if he wants to have a two formal
expression input
kind of as i guess this is a special
case of the problem that jose was
fighting up uh it becomes quite hard for
you to enter anything into the theorem
prover because
you would need to have a way of flagging
that something shouldn't be that an
operator shouldn't be formalized
well and what you're effectively saying
is and this is
this is descending rapidly into the mud
is that we really need a sequent
calculus one and an equational
logic one and so on which already know
that their special things are such and
such and such and such
but but how do you how do you specify
whether you're using the special version
of the operator or the non-special
version of the operator
you still have that you need to have
some escape right but because
what you're saying okay so here's the
question could there be two equality i
mean this is the point
you're you're you're freeloading on our
notation in a sense you're you're using
i mean
okay in version three we had this plan
that we were providing lots of
essentially
non-meaningful syntactic forms like
circle plus
which people could then attach to things
just like okay
so here's the here's the question of why
didn't it work out okay
in math in standard math you know people
typing things with tech and so on and so
on and so on
something like circle let's say circle
times
right there a zillion different uses of
circle times it's been recruited
for things in group theory it's been
recruited for things in tensor algebra
you know
they're somewhat related but they're not
quite the same right
circle plus could be recruited for many
purposes
right that's what i thought was going to
happen with our non-meaningful operators
now arguably the reason it didn't happen
is because people wanted you know
non-meaningful all the way through
that is we gave them things which were
and even later on
we made things like element for example
that had been non-meaningful
then become meaningful does this make
sense
so you might have thought that in all of
our formal
stuff here you know we're using circle
plus here
which is one of our family of
non-meaningful operators
you know the argument would be we maybe
we just don't have enough non-meaningful
operators
or maybe we need a a better convention
for how
all the non-meaningful operators would
work
anybody want to comment on this michael
do you want to comment on this
so i had problems unmuting
it seems very heavy somehow
which seems very heavy did this this
permanent distinction between meaningful
and non-meaningful
well the main problem is we're trying if
we
if everything was full form there'd be
no problem the point is we're trying to
use syntax
does everybody agree about that
statement
you know if i could just use plus with a
lowercase p
and all that kind of thing or or even
something called you know
uh field theory plus or something
you know if i was able to do all of this
stuff a very heavy weight
full form then there'd be no problem the
difficulty is we're trying to kind of
piggyback on our syntactic struct
structure
that's certainly true for the theorem
proving case yeah
um so the issue is and and when we
piggyback
on the syntactic structure
certain things we are grandfathering
over
from the meaning based case of the of
the syntax structure
like for example you know we're pulling
over precedences we're pulling over
associativities
which may or may not be i mean the
precedence is we're toast there's
nothing we can do about that
if we blow up the precedences you might
as well not be using you know syntax
if you see what i'm saying but we also
kind of take
over the meaning otherwise we in some
sense the meaning otherwise we wouldn't
use the symbol in the first place
if like the plus would not in some form
represent plus we wouldn't use it
i agree except that it is a very
generalized plus
but we're happy we don't want
any of the rules that are in the
built-in plus we don't want them
touching us
i mean so as we could have as a
convention they go into a context
and there they format a slightly
different way
oh yeah that's an interesting idea okay
so there's a okay that's an interesting
idea
use okay so what are our possibilities
use different symbols
okay the user context now in a context
okay user context now the problem with
the context is plus
doesn't parse differently in a different
context
usually but you would have to fight it
out
plus yeah
right well i mean it's it's worse than
that so
i i so this behavior has existed
basically since version three
which i presume was some attempt along
this discussion we're having right now
but do
fubactic plus of a b
but now if you copy and paste that
output and do full form of it
you will get the system plus not the
gosh why how does that work
that's crazy what happens if i say foo
of of like let's say bessel j
i i don't think that'll do anything
because it's
it's not associated with an operator
this is crazy bonkers though i had no
idea this happened
really what what why did we do this
i think you need to ask yourself of 25
years ago
or or possibly uh neil uh
i i like i said this has been around for
a very long time
uh john may know a little bit about it
but it's it's
something that people run into every now
and then and so i i am aware of it's
existed
it's crazy it seems completely bonkers
to me
or maybe we should look at the code can
somebody look at the code and see if it
has comments
uh that will i i could not not not in
real time because it it'll
i'd have to search for it yeah okay we
should look at that
i had no idea no idea something
hidden deep in the infrastructure of the
of the world so to speak
okay but but back to okay let's just
zoom out again what are we trying to do
as michael says when we type plus in the
axioms of field theory we're doing it
because
it resonates it reminds us of plus but
it no more reminds us of plus
than when you when you type p l u s in
the name of a symbol
which we're doing so it reminds us of
plus even though it's lowercase p
it's kind of a light you know hat tip to
plus
it's not intended to be it really is
plus
it kind of you know it looks like it
looks like a duck but it isn't a duck
i don't know if that's very useful um
the
but so the claim is
you know the only thing we're trying to
use the only thing we want to use
is special forms
special forms of operators and their
precedence
no it's more than their precedence and
their precedence and
the way that they pick up arguments like
a
plus b going to the full form right
right that's not quite impressive
they're they're parsing info
right and the and they're basic parsing
see the question is what's the analogy
between this
and your average piece of tech input
that might have completely meaningless
uses i mean like like
for example one can imagine a notation
in which people are using i don't know
some operator which is normally a binary
operator let's say
xor but you're using it as a prefix
operator
well people do that all the time right
if i know they do
if they're if they're doing uh you know
some sort of
xor over an indefinite number of
variables
exactly right but my question is
you know when people type right now when
people type arbitrary tech
we are not really seriously trying to
pause it
correct
and i think that is hopeless to
seriously try to parse it
so in a sense again we are inventing i
mean so
okay what are our choices here we can
have something which is
a a complete
grammar for formal things
then the question is what operators are
we using and what what symbols and
operators are we using
in the land of formal things
and if we have a whole another family of
those okay then there are two questions
what operators are you using and how do
you type them
right because that's one of the problems
is that it becomes extremely hard to
type these things
and if we had a way of sort of
formalizing stuff
okay the question is a possible string
um okay so can i just mention one one of
the reasons i
don't particularly like the idea of just
like a you know slash formal plus
like we have slash formal a which i
think is kind of what you're assuming
when you say to formal expression
one of the reasons i don't like that is
we
for full generality again at least in
the theorem proving case we need to be
able to have multiple
formal different formalized copies of
the same operator
within the same axiom system
[Music]
why i mean so imagine the case of
axiomatizing
vector spaces or modules or something
like there you have
there's addition of the in the
underlying field of scalars and then
there's addition of the vectors
and those are two different operations
yep but they
are they're both right or or algebras
are even worse right
because you have scalar multiplication
and and vector multiplication which is
something completely you know in the
module case uh
you you see the straight line between
the two additions whereas in
the algebra they're they're quite
different
okay question um
um how much is there a taxonomy
of these kinds of things like you say
there isn't really i mean there could be
a scalar plus a tensor plus a you know
vector plus a tensor plus
an axial vector plus who knows what
right right the the point is that the
plus symbol carries a lot of weight
there are lots of different essentially
different operations that are denoted
with plus
many of which can occur within the same
algebraic structure
and so you need we need to have some way
of
okay my point is that a formal you know
a slash formal plus or something is not
sufficient we need to
where's the slash going from you mean
you mean the dot dotted yeah
he he's talking referring to the long
name the the backslash
open bracket oh okay right
um we ideally would want some kind of
parameterized version of that
if that makes sense which i think is
where you were going with the container
that is somehow tagged
idea right so you have like a formal of
string
plus you know scalar plus and formal
of the string vector plus
and i suppose if you're doing tensor
analysis right then you need one plus
for each
rank and the kind of tensor right
because those are technically different
pluses as well
right if i may say i think we're having
a similar
discussion to the previous time in the
sense that this was motivated by
we need more operators and so i said
well let's have just a few more
so that we cover our new needs and then
we went to the
let's solve the whole problem of having
any
but i think this other problem is too
difficult
which problem the problem of of the any
of the any
of the any number of the
parameterization it's just this is a
space too big to parametrize correctly
and if we if we give
names like tensor plus or something like
that users
know before it's hopeless yeah that's
hopeless i agree that's hopeless
okay so let's let's zoom out for a
minute okay
the thing we've been very that's been
very successful
is our fundamental symbolic expression
form
with words names
character strings that represent things
has been thoroughly successful over the
years
right not a problem now what's the
difference here
okay i've got an idea okay
so the difference is we're trying to
push into a single character
all this functionality now we already
have something
which is the tilde operator which has
not been particularly widely used
but that is a way of essentially merging
syntactic you know it's it's a way of
merging an infix
operator but with a name right so
for for jonathan's you know scalar plus
for example right we could perfectly
well this isn't very elegant but
you know this would be a thing right
that would just work
right i mean you would just need to
[Music]
right it would have the natural
precedence of
of infects which is very high uh
so okay so there's a president yeah
there's a precedence issue here
now
and i wonder how we'd solve that but the
point that i'm making is
the way to deal with the any
is to have sort of meta operator
wrappers
so that the the operators can be named
the same way we've been naming things
for 35 years with with strings of
characters
okay so let's imagine that the meta
operator wrapper
okay this is starting to be a decent
idea let's imagine that the meta
operator wrapper could have things like
plus inside it
that it was similar to the way that we
do meta things for i don't know
less than less than can deal with you
know slashes and things like that
in other words it switches off by the
time you've used the meta operator
it switched off the usual parsing of
what's in the inside
you see what i'm saying
but that somehow this could
um
um so i i i mean
it's something we could explore but uh
off the top of my head it is not at all
obvious that that is something that's
even
personal i mean obviously it's not now
but
i'm i'm just saying it's so obvious that
this is
right but you know clearly if that was
an escape yes i understand
um
although i guess we don't have any
compound operators that use
tilde so maybe i'm not kidding this
particular thing i'm not i see a
particular thing
i'm just saying some meta operator
that wraps an arbitrary packet of
operator-like
stuff and potentially gets the
precedence if that's doable i don't know
if that's doable
gets its precedence from the the the
payload
right so what we would need is so this
is the idea that's the meta operators
wrapping you know
payloads and so the meta operators would
be a a
you know a meta we have this sort of
meta operator
um which is you know the prefix meta
operator the post fix and so on
and then you know infix meta et et
cetera the bad names but but whatever i
mean
in um um
the uh i think this is the only doable
thing because this allows us to get
the any idea and if those
you know for allowed arbitrary things in
here the full form of this object would
be
what the heck is the full form the full
form will be some kind of you know
formal operator of
you know plus comma blah blah blah blah
blah
and then applied to the the expression
see what i'm saying so formal the the
the full form be pretty heavy
but that's okay
yeah obviously this is something i would
need to
discuss with i i think this would be
doable on the front end but you know
that's something i need to discuss with
well right remember we have to
the question is what the metro operators
how the metro operators work
right because and the real question is
letting
precedence seep out of the innards of
the meta operator
you know what given what jonathan has
said if we're serious about using
um
i mean gosh you know
i mean we do have a small number of
things where where
where like some right that's an operator
and you can but you can turn it into a
sub superscript
or or an under over script box and it
still has the precedence of some
because yeah i get it so
i mean right but maybe this is a general
mechanism i mean maybe what we
are doing here is inventing a general
mechanism
for introducing so then maybe we have
two different problems
we have
you know
these things don't need formal variables
we need because we can assign values to
variables
i don't know but we're making progress
here this is not a bad idea this this
this insight that we need to leverage
the high diversity
way of labeling things which is with
character strings
seems like a good insight that we're not
going to be able to stuff it into you
know
oh we'll introduce another you know a
triple tilde just to represent that
that's basically that's the import of
what jonathan is saying is that a fair
statement
i i think so if if we want a you know a
long-term solution
um always a good thing to have i mean on
the other hand
if we just care about kind of making
axiomatic theory more extensible then i
think jose's idea is not a bad one which
is just
have more things that are like circle
plus and circle times
but yeah but it's gonna get very obscure
go ahead
but we might want some of the things not
just for representation purposes but for
active computations
like you have some associative algebra
and you want to really add rules for
computation rather than just sitting it
there
so what i mean you can add rules for
circle plus
yes but you can't add anything
to the formal one so they would be
different as formal operators you could
add with to them well you could always
do
replacements right yes yeah
i don't know without adding rules to
them i mean that's a whole nother
question i mean then we've got things
like the the combinator disaster
of um you know of of you can't add rules
because
the you know not all evaluation orders
terminate and it's all rather
complicated
yeah but it's then up to you to as well
as they do something sensible
yeah but is that in fact common that
that the that the canonical form because
i mean
one thing is use the theorem prover to
get to a canonical form the other is
which is
allows you a multi-way story and the
other way is use
our traditional evaluation semantics to
get to a grammatical form
and do we think the traditional
evaluation semantics is going to be a
common thing
let's say you see you want you want a
nicely
accumulator
yes you can fight come off something you
can make some format rules for it and
everything
yes right all right we are making
progress guys
we should pick this up again and um
you know we need to this is one that it
seems to me we've got
several you know we're just finishing a
version so we we get a chance to think
about bigger things
we've got several things from the string
diagram stuff to these formal variable
things
you know these are these are some heavy
lifting and they're things that have
been around
for multiple decades but i think we
should now
feel ourselves empowered to solve them
that's my theory at least anyway
okay so let's just so we're clear so are
you saying we should
resume this discussion in our next
meeting or that we should go and wander
and come i think we should probably re i
mean if there's
there's a few specific things to go look
at as homework
but i think we should resume this okay
and either in this meeting or in a
custom meeting
okay all right thank you all very much
thanks to folks on the live stream and
um
talk to you all soon okay okay